So this is a list of all the political parties
I'll be going through leading up to the elections.
The first group of parties over here
is parties who actually have seats in parliament.
The more votes you get,
the more seats you get in Parliament
or the National Assembly.
This means that when bills need to be passed
or other decisions need to be made,
the party with the most seats will obviously
have the biggest say on the decisions that are made
because they have the most votes.
And this is in descending order.
So a, N, C having the most seats,
all the way down to Algemai
having the least seats.
The second group of parties over here is parties that
don't have any seats in National Assembly,
but you've asked me to speak about them.
Most of them are pretty much horseshit,
And I'll explain exactly why I say that
in the weeks coming up.
I am taking note of all your comments
and all the things
you want to know about these political parties,
as well as what you want to see
in your ideal political party
and what you want them to live up to.
So we'll be doing this
right throughout the year into 2024.